[Music]
have you ever been scammed on craigslist
or something have you guys it's crazy
it's like the way you fall into this
trap is because your brain like so badly
wants to believe that it's real i think
i got scammed one time for like an
airbnb or something like that and we
like showed up to the place and then
realized we got scammed it was like i
know this is real it has to be real it
has to be real even though like every
warning sign saying it's fake the guy's
not responding anymore yeah the pictures
are found on other websites and you're
like no it has to be real you went to
the actual address provided was there an
address no that that was that wasn't me
that was my friends gotcha it was a like
they rented it as an airbnb for a
vacation
and then the guy stopped responding and
they were like oh [ __ ] it like let's
just go he probably and then they
arrived at the place and it wasn't an
airbnb that happened to us we were
supposed to go somewhere for like new
year's one year and i remember the
person handling it was like okay we're
all set and everyone chipped in and then
they were like yeah it's super weird
they stopped answering we couldn't get a
response and everyone was like what the
[ __ ] is going on and they were like yeah
we western union them the money and we
were like yeah yeah
yeah damn wow immediately why did we do
that oh yeah why did they ask for
western union and now imagine being in
love with someone and they're like i'm
my life is in danger you would have no
choice but to be like okay i'm going to
give you money i want to do whatever it
takes the images and [ __ ] that he uses
from like the attack are [ __ ] real
like the dude's head is like like a gash
in it like they're in the back of an
ambulance like something that they
didn't do a good job in the documentary
of is context on the size of this
bodyguard there's one shot you see him
he's [ __ ] huge like compared to the
guy who's the subject this guy's like
three like 280 yeah so if you've met
that guy and then you see a video of him
later like all [ __ ] up and beat up
you're gonna think damn whoever attacked
them beat the [ __ ] out of that guy they
must be scary i think that lends to you
know like the i'm in danger i need money
now dang i want to watch the tinder
swindler now those producers sure are
lucky he did it on tinder and not
something like hinge because how do you
make come up with a good name for that
the hinge
heckler the plenty of fish robbery
i remember plenty of fish i'm in an
argentinian pole dancer on there and she
didn't have a car i drove all the way
from long beach to glendale where she
lived and she was really cute didn't
quite look like how she looked in her
photos but she insisted she wanted to
meet a cheesecake factory oh let's go i
actually [ __ ] love cheese and we're
back i drove her home obviously because
she didn't drive dropped her off in
front of her house and we started a kiss
not only she had gum in her mouth
pocketed it in the side of her mouth and
i at one point pulled back and i was
like do you want to spit out your gum
and she said okay she spit it out and
then oh man did i have to pee so bad so
we uh said goodbye and then i pulled
over in her neighborhood and just
emptied it out and then get this i
didn't see her or talked to her again
for a couple years until i went to
jumbo's clown room oh that's the
hollywood boulevard where she dances oh
and she was dancing she gets up to do a
song and she picked uh i don't even
remember what it was but it was some
song that was meaningful to me and i was
like damn is this destiny and it wasn't
and she's like oh ben remember it's me
kelly i don't even remember her name no
because destiny's like a common stripper
that was funny
that was really funny damn that's right
over my head yeah but that's not a strip
club that's a pole dancing joint very
different i just went there for the
first time too it's cool huh wild place
yeah it is really cool yeah it's uh
it's a burlesque it's not burlesque it's
it's their actual like baby they're
strippers but they don't strip they get
like very close to naked that's what
burlesque is right no but they're like
isn't it like a choreographed
performance yes and there's no poles
yeah burlesque is when they have like
the
like the big dresses and the shows yeah
kind of a bit of a square rectangle
situation yeah they come out and they go
i don't know what it is they make fun of
you for being horny yeah okay hey
this is weird look at these men with the
little penises
they're the venn diagram of
white women who love pitbulls have
tattoos yeah and are uh doing burlesque
is almost a perfect circle you can't be
into one without being into the other
day have you guys been to the famous
portland strip club the the vegan place
the vegan place yeah it's like a vegan
strip club yeah it's just like super
portland it's like vegan and all the
girls are like suicide girls oh okay
yeah my hairdresser growing up was one
of those girls a suicide cereal
she could vegan
okay i'm kidding uh no she was in a
rockabilly band she was like a 50s pinup
girl crazy blonde hair like gwen stefani
style yeah with the big like played
stand-up bass in a rock damn that she
was super rockabilly super cool like
kind of like a hot rod man she is way
cooler than me my little brother is
rockabilly adjacent yeah he's got a a
couple of super old cars oh um they're
really cool no nate oh sam i don't know
sam is an enigma my brother sam is just
i'm gonna say yeah like nobody knows
where he fits in pictures sam like
like i don't know i feel like he's
figured out like an alternate method of
transportation that none of us it's just
a jeep no i feel like i could see him
just like cartwheeling at high speeds
playing heartwheel yeah high speeds yeah
man that boy is not physically adept but
that's what i'm
he just gives out this vibe where like i
could see him on tech talk being like
hey guys i figured out this crazy way to
get somewhere and then he just
cartwheels at 50 miles an hour i could
see that for him and you're like how the
[ __ ] and he's like i don't know
you